Ich bin Unteroffizier beim österreichischem Bundesheer.
Mein Verband ist das Aufklärungs- und Artilleriebataillon 7 in Feldbach,
wo ich als Aufklärungsgruppenkommandant tätig bin.
Aufklärung, wobei wir hier von der Taktischen Erdaufklärung sprechen,
beinhaltet die Speeraufklärung, die Drohnenaufklärung und die Radaraufklärung.
Die Beobachtungsstelle wird mit technischem Equipment betrieben,
wobei Spiegelreflexkameras, Spektive und gehärtete Computer zum Einsatz kommen.
Unterstützt werden wir von Drohnenaufklärung
und Radaraufklärung.
In einem Gefechtsstand finden Planung, Führung und zb. Befehlsausgaben statt.
Während des Einsatzes laufen hier die Informationen zusammen,
aufgrund welcher dann Führungsentscheidungen getroffen werden.
Die Artillerie erstellt mit den ausgewerteten Daten der Aufklärungstruppe einen Feuerunterstützungsplan
und stellt mit ihren Hauptwaffensystem, der Panzerhaubitze,
die weitreichende Feuerunterstützung sicher.